um all right so how many dates left on
the tour uh probably like I think still
like a good 20 some [ __ ] so you're
writing the thick of it man yeah this is
like just it's just turning up right now
what's been your favorite city so far I
liked I liked all the dates honestly and
I know tonight about to be crazy but
I've been having fun is my [ __ ] like
how the hell am I have one favorite date
out my [ __ ] has there been a fan that
was a little unhinged like a crazy
person maybe they got a tattoo or
they're like throwing their [ __ ]
draws up at you or something I had a
dude last night who kept calling my
government name and like from the crowd
yeah and like was like like just saying
stuff at me to like I don't like I don't
lie but he followed me saying some crazy
ass [ __ ] was he what was he saying to
you like Interview with the Vampire type
stuff
was he like yo I'll suck your dick bruh
hey over here
have you ever had to like um no deal
with a crazy fan where they like maybe
cross the line showed up your hotel try
to get on your bus
[ __ ] be chasing our cars bro like
running like full like 25 30 miles per
hour I'm assuming white
let's be crazy really like straight like
World War Z type like [ __ ] I'm coming I
need this picture like hey World War Z
zombies
we just had to talk about this like four
hours ago actually me and my co-host on
my radio show we were saying
there's this zombie virus that got
discovered uh at the bottom of this
river that was like 50 000 years old
right
and I was like well if we had to pick
any type of zombies if they were real
I would hope they'd be like Walking Dead
zombies not where was these zombies
World War Z zombies
ain't gonna lie to a [ __ ] like me
who what zombie I'm taking all this
you're like the LeBron of zombies
zombies is coming and a [ __ ] like me
who played cry zombies all day I'm
wearing that [ __ ] up you got it what
and I got real sticks so tell the zombie
come my way that [ __ ] getting put down
well you do live in uh you're in Georgia
yep yeah but that ain't the conversation
I'm just saying it's a lot easier for
you to have realistics I'm speaking
hypothetically like if this was a zombie
apocalypse of course yeah shout out to
the zombie apocalypse man yep